another williams as well so it's like
come on guys
so
maybe we just need to change our names
to marshall then we're all okay
so yeah you know i'll go frank you can
go bob and bob marshall let's see what
what is like the the
uh sort of opening in chess
the freshest that is actually you know
something that is used a lot like the
spanish or i mean just while we've got
him on camera magnus i'm not sure his
eyes are open there but just while we've
got him on camera
there is a carlson variation now against
the sicilian um which is relatively new
i think it was only developed a few
years ago um it was actually suggested
to magnus and uh peter heiner nielsen
his his coach it was suggested to them
by i think a fide master an
international master he sent them all
the notes and carlson was the first one
to play it and first one to kind of
bring it to the top level and now it's
super trendy everyone's playing
i mean i think there's something like 1
600 different openings um roughly around
there it used to be like 1 500 and
something so there's